peu
où les créateurs de la haute coiffure
parisienne of steel l'inspiration en
contemplant les visages féminins
sûrement et le visage de nicole courcel
est un ravissant point de départ en
allant dans les expositions aux courses
à la montagne en asie au cinéma quelques
fois ainsi dans le dernier film de walt
disney que nous verrons à paris en avril
prochain
le personnage principal et davy crockett
trappeur chasseurs d'ours qui a
participé brillamment à l'indépendance
du texas et qui traverse le folklore
américain coiffé de cette toque de
fourrure qui va si bien à nicole courcel
[Musique]
topp qui attend plus un célèbre trio de
coiffeur parisien qu'ils ont créé des
postiches de cheveux rappelant le bonnet
de davy crockett pour rester là blain
cheveux bruns je vous rassure sa tête et
cheveux bruns pour imiter la fourrure
car cette dup est un cheveu
[Musique]
et en cheveux également mais en cheveux
de plusieurs temps là que de la tom
hooper
[Musique]
pour ginette pigeons aux cheveux blonds
et courts
le postiche sera naturellement un cheveu
blanc et l'ensemble vous allez en juger
postiches et cheveux sourire et beaux
yeux et extrêmement séduisant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]